[Musique]
bonjour l'intelligence bonjour bertrand
caruge bonjour toute la martinique et
tous les foyers à l'aise et les foyalais
alors vous êtes candidate en tête de
liste de la liste lien nage pour les v
faute france alors vous aviez déjà été
tête de liste aux élections de la ctm la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
en décembre 2015
et vous aviez obtenu au premier tour 3,1
des suffrages de 3,1 pour cent des
suffrages exprimés alors est-ce que
c'est ce résultat de 2015 intelligence
que vous avez trouvé encourageant qui
vous a poussé donc cette fois ci à vous
présenter aux municipales à fort de
france il ya beaucoup de ça ya beaucoup
de ça parce qu'on avait fait
effectivement à cette occasion une très
belle performance
et je dois vous dire que ces idées que
nous avions mis en avant qui étaient les
idées citoyennes de remettre le citoyen
au centre du débat public
tout monde semoun de transparence
d'évaluation des politiques publiques de
conseils de citoyens voilà ces idées là
ont beaucoup marqué les gens et on
n'arrête pas de m'en parler jusqu'à
présent j'ai une forte
enfin nous avons une forte demande nous
en martinique citoyenne on nous demande
beaucoup mais pourquoi vous avez lâché
il faut remettre ces idées là au centre
du débat politique et c'est pour ça que
nous avons choisi de nous relancer
au premier plan électoral et y compris
pour des municipales donc ça ça vaut
pour ce type d'élection oui ça vaut
peut-être plus encore pour ce genre
d'élection puisque c'est une élection de
proximité ou là on est vraiment en
contact avec la population sur des
problématiques qui concernent
directement le quotidien des gens et
donc c'est une élection qui se prête
vraiment à la participation citoyenne
puisque il faut véritablement
aujourd'hui que le citoyen trouve sa
place dans la politique municipale et
singulièrement de la politique foyer à
l'aise où il était quand même assez
singulièrement absent aujourd'hui
alors certains pourraient dire que l est
pas si citoyenne que ça cette liste
alors c'est vrai il ya martinique
citoyenne mais c'est surtout le résultat
d'une alliance de trois mouvements alors
c'est une liste hybride singulière
certaines dirais même
atypique un alors c'est le regroupement
de martinique citoyenne la france a
soumises et pays acp
non il n'y a rien de singulier là dedans
au contraire nous avons fait une
alliance alors pour plusieurs choses
évidemment remettre le citoyen au centre
de la politique c'est vrai mais aussi on
nous sommes accordés sur le fait qu'il
fallait s'élever au dessus des corps
elle des querelles intestines qu'il
fallait vraiment redorer le blason de la
politique nous on a envie que les
citoyens on retrouve confiance en la
politique au sens noble et retrouve
confiance en leurs élus et donc c'est ce
qui nous a motivés nous voulons
réenchanter la politique et dire que on
peut avoir une politique qui prône la
morale une politique voilà qui qui qui
se fait avec des valeurs et donc nous
voulons remettre un peu de valeur et non
pas des stratégies et des ddd des
stratégies politiques à mettre en place
nous on veut un débat d'idées on veut
que aujourd'hui la politique se fasse
avec des idées et que ce soit projet
contre projet et qu'on discute des idées
avant de discuter des stratégies
politiques électoralistes et cetera
nous avons très envie qu'on discute par
exemple de d'une vision pour
fort-de-france qu'est ce que nous allons
faire de fort de france alors on va on
va y venir on va y venir vous avez des
propositions vous avez certainement
peut-être même un programme
mais comment rapidement comment l'avez
vous constituer cette liste comment est
elle constituée est ce que c'est un
savant équilibre savant dosage justement
entre ces trois mouvements martinique
citoyenne pays et la france est selon
nous ce que nous mettons sous lycées des
gens qui ont envie de faire des choses
qui ont envie de se battre pour
fort-de-france qui ont envie que fort de
france devienne qui redevient une
arithmétique entre deux pays à trois
francs six sous et vraiment et je vous
assure
sans langue de bois sans petits calculs
électoraux non on s'est vraiment dit
voilà qui a envie que fort de france
retrouve son lustre qui est compétent à
tel niveau qui connaît l'action sociale
qui peut s'occuper lemieux de
l'environnement du développement
économique de cette ville
nous avons des banquiers qui sont
experts vous savez que ya une grosse
dette financière dans cette ville donc
il ya des banquiers qu'ils nous disent
comment comment on va faire comment on
va faire pour redresser véritablement
les finances de cette ville donc on met
les bonnes personnes au bon endroit et
ça c'est important aussi
alors pour terminer justement votre
thématique de campagne c'est l'écologie
politique citoyenne avec donc une forte
matic sur la protection de
l'environnement et la transition
énergétique je me trompe pas tout cela
assorti d'un volet social aussi donc
allez-y
quels sont vos wii voilà vous avez très
bien l'expliquer c'est tout à fait ça
nous nous tournons vers ce qu'on appelle
l'écocitoyenneté foyalaise parce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui tourner cette ville
véritablement dans engagé cette ville
dans une transition énergétique dans une
transition écologique parce que elle
souffre de trop de handicaps de
stationnement d'embouteillage
d'accessibilité et il faudra
véritablement travail de travail et un
transport un transport gratuit
ao je sais que l'on nous dit on pourra
pas financer oui c'est possible de
financer un transport gratuit parce que
ça ça va faire que le transport sera
plus propre que le volet social sera
plus développés les décharges les vhs
qui vraiment pourri cette ville
véritablement la remette lui donner de
l'esthétique et en faire une très belle
ville une ville qui mérite sa place de
capitale vraiment c'est ce que nous
voulons redonner à fort de france sa
place de capitale capitale de la caraïbe
que les gens aient envie d'y venir
merci nathalie josse ça aux cadis
spécial municipal réalisé par claudine
était le biel
[Musique]